à milan sur la piazza del duomo des
tories sont refusés devant l'entrée de
la cathédrale écoles universités mais
aussi musées cinémas et théâtres dont la
prestigieuse scala sont fermés jusqu'à
nouvel ordre
les bars baisseront le rideau de 18h à
6h du matin des mesures que comprennent
les milanais il s'agit d'une mesure de
précaution total et je pense donc que
cette décision a été importante bien
qu'elle soit drastique à certains égards
mais étant donné la situation il ne faut
ni sous-estimer ni surestimer ce qui
nous arrive
la fermeture des principaux espaces
publics peut être un choix équitables
partageable ou non c'est certainement
une bonne précaution si quelque chose
est fermé pendant quelques jours il ne
se passe rien à 60 kilomètres de là la
police effectue des contrôles routiers à
l'entrée de la ville de casa plus ternes
ngô situe à quelques kilomètres de
codorniou la ville considéré comme le
foyer de l'épidémie de la péninsule
aucune voiture ne peut entrer et sortir
les 15000 habitants se retrouvent peu à
peu coupé du monde
seules les pharmacies et quelques
supermarchés reste ouvert même si ses
clients ont eu moins de chance
alors qu'il devait rouvrir ce lundi ce
magasin est finalement resté portes
closes des supermarchés qui sont pris
d'assaut comme ici à rozzano où les
clients littéralement dévalisé les
rayons
au total depuis samedi ce sont plus de
cinquante mille personnes qui vivent
confinés pour tenter d'éviter la
propagation du virus
a venise les derniers jours du carnaval
ont été annulées
il devait se dérouler jusqu'à mardi
[Musique]